I'm not even hearing about this in the
news I mean I didn't know that there was
another autonomous it's been there for
like a year and a half yeah which which
is absolutely crazy because the last
time we kind of saw this it was in
Portland and it was widely talked about
and people were trying to film in there
but there's there's nothing about uh any
of this that I've been actually hearing
about myself but to be fair I mean we
were really wrapped up talking about
Stephen Crowder yesterday I mean we
couldn't we couldn't spare any time I
talk about antifa terrorists getting
arrested and trying to kill police so is
this a situation where they're like this
is our land and then the cop stepped on
their land and they're like don't you're
invading our territory Bang Bang the
cops were going to use the facility as a
training facility right they want to
build a training center exactly and so a
bunch of
Psychopaths from all over the country
show up pretending they're angry that
Atlanta's doing this and then living in
trees and trying to kill people you